you now from climate change to flights
being changed american airlines is
scrambling to get back on track after
canceling more than 1800 flights from
friday through sunday its hub in dallas
fort worth has been particularly hit
hard errol barnett has been following
this for us arrow what's going on with
all of these cancellations
hey there nate good morning look
american airlines appears to be
suffering from the same pandemic pain
that befell spirit airlines in august
and southwest airlines after that thin
staffing plus poor weather conditions
equals logistical chaos and of course
with the holidays now just a few weeks
away airlines are hiring to meet demand
but we're all wondering how likely is
this to happen again here's what we know
american airlines says 50 mile per hour
cross winds at dallas-fort worth airport
on thursday closed three out of its five
runways that drove a large number of
cancellations they say putting staff out
of place by sunday the airline canceled
more than a third of its schedule and in
total more than 2 000 flights were cut
now american says most passengers are
being rebooked same day but just look at
what folks had to go through this was
the scene at dallas fort worth yesterday
scores of passengers there grappling
with that dreaded last minute change of
travel plans and one big reason we're
seeing this is that during the pandemic
many airlines reduce their schedules and
thus cut staff and evidently many of
them are struggling now to meet current
demand and so if you're booking tickets
get those protections because it very
likely could happen again gail
i know errol i was at the airport in l.a
yesterday it was not pretty thank you
very much